[Music]
foreign
[Music]
or is their most Sinister side to this
entity if you really think about it the
events of the two movies show that this
deity of the navi acts as more than just
a manifestation of a supernatural form
but something that is really alien to us
humans more alien to us than the blue
humanoids and all the creatures of that
planet Moon
so what does AWA according to the navi
known as the old mother or the great
mother the navi believed that AWA
maintains Pandora's biosphere in perfect
balance and that all creatures returned
to her after death even across Clans the
navi share many core principles like
their belief in a globally spread
awareness of Pandora known to them as
AWA the navi believe that the souls of
the disease returned to AWA before being
reincarnated in an unending cycle of
death and rebirth natural catastrophe is
sickness and all that are just a result
of worldly forces and she acts as a life
Defender and a guide to the navi against
such attacks
but what is AWA according to the humans
and the RDA of that universe well
according to Grace Augustine the lead
borderness and scientific researcher AWA
is a conglomeration of all the life of
Pandora connected by a vast network of
interconnected roots of trees acting as
sort of a brain cell mass for the entire
planet with internodal connections far
surprising a human brain and magnitude
the uniqueness of Botanical life in that
planet Moon allows for the roots to
become like neural Pathways therefore
resulting in a strange alien
intelligence kind of like a super
organism other humans treat AWA as just
a deity worship by the navi and most of
them consider her something that doesn't
exist in real life but one thing is for
sure and that is she is an entity and is
really present but as to what kind is
still in question a superorganism having
super intelligence is one viable
scenario something like the arachnids of
Starship Troopers with each individual
but having a life of its own but still
acting under the will of the God but she
could also be a hive mind as all the
creatures of Pandora except for the
Tolkien and certain Navi were willing to
take up arms and attack humans on site
while at the same time ignoring their
Natural Instincts of hunting or killing
each other with carnivores and
herbivores working together against an
alien threat something which is far from
being natural in the lease like anywhere
so is a were really a hive mind
something akin to the ones seen in the
swamp creatures like the Zerg of
Starcraft the tyranids of Warhammer the
flood of Halo or even movies such as
Resident Evil and Starship Troopers well
let's look at the details and facts that
might support this claim well firstly it
is said that the trace of Pandora are
akin to brain cells and the roots are
interconnected with each other with the
network connections being 20 times more
than a human brain therefore if this is
true then the entity would have a super
intelligence vastly different and
Superior to a human and intellect and
computing power and this is evident in
her controlling and commanding the
animals to attack humans simultaneously
in the last battle of the first movie as
well as maintaining them as sort of like
antiviral cells or a global immune
system that would continue to be hostile
to human presence
what if she is like ego of The Living
Planet you know the celestial from the
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2. if you
think about it this isn't really a
far-fetched Theory except for the fact
that ego has a distinct human-like
personality which is malevolent and can
create an avatar of himself in human
form ego is still a living planet
meaning that all the various plants and
animal life on his surface are
extensions of himself
kind of like the animals and plants of
Pandora being an integral part of Eva
and all submit to her or act on her will
so therefore in essence they are
extensions of her although having more
autonomous lives this as well as her
regulating the biosphere as if it's her
own body even to the point of wiping
entire Navi population clean off the map
if they exceed a certain threshold is
evident of a living planet and an even
greater argument for in favor of AWA
being a hive mind and a dangerous one at
that
and lastly the most interesting detail
or facts and these are the three laws of
AWA which were given to the navi
populations by her and they are as
follows well the first one is you shall
not set stone upon Stone
the second one is neither shall you use
the Turning wheel and the last one is
nor use the metals of the ground at
surface level they sound like clear
environmental guidelines for the navi
but here in our discussion this sounds
like an eerie warning against developing
technology which would allow the
sentient Navi or even the Tolkien for
that matter to eventually gaze of world
and truly become autonomous beings out
of the control of AWA breaking off from
the hive mind which would be a net loss
and it's something that in our
experience of Hive Minds in pop culture
is akin to blasphemy and heresy so yes
in our conclusion AWA is a hive mind a
powerful one but one that isn't
hell-bent on Galactic domination not yet
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on on this channel
till the next one take care fam
[Music]